remembering a life taken too soon avid
motorcycle rider william defalco was
killed in a crash last saturday in north
las vegas tonight his friends and family
are coming together near the crash site
to honor him madison kimbrough joins us
live near craig and decatur with a look
ahead of that ceremony madison
we're here at craig road car wash where
defalco was a manager for almost two
decades and everyone here will
participate in the vigil happening
tonight near anne road at 6 p.m now to
give you a bit of a backstory defalco
was riding his motorcycle to work last
saturday morning when he was hit by a
speeding sedan that ran a red light that
sedan crashed into his motorcycle on ann
road and defalco was declared dead on
scene tonight we hear from his family
and friends remembering the cuban native
who built a community here in las vegas
around craig road car wash and detail
center fellow co-worker charlie drake
used to ride with defalco and says ever
since the crash he's been lost
i haven't touched my motorcycle since
last week i parked it
i don't know what to do yet it's just
not going to be the same for us here
i lost a brother co-worker and a friend
as for the man who hit him 29-year-old
thomas munoz was arrested and faces
several charges including dui causing
death again the vigil starts at 6 p.m
near the crash site 8 news now has been
invited to the vigil so we will be
bringing you live coverage reporting
near craig and decatur madison kimbrough
live local now